let's talk a little bit it's couple
things you should know it that I've
never really told you and we've known
each other a long time I'm a little bit
of an amateur Herbert ologist well pop
well did you bring up my Instagram this
is I did yeah and we're gonna talk about
this little late today Baba went deep
and true into the mountains deep drone
he went deep and drove it true now did
you have any run-ins with the law zero
okay now they probably they put up signs
for Papa now to make you very clear that
they're not open and that's okay what I
do okay run right through sure can we
zoom in on this Jim said at all possible
yeah now I'm gonna say this now now so
if you if you see my post I want
whatever you want to call it you know
sure danger knew definitely not I
definitely not a grabber because I took
what I liked it but you can see there's
no rattle on here when I stumble upon
one I like to just flicked a few rocks
at see what's gonna do just just kind of
add to stick your finger in the cage
poke the bear a little bit this thing
with suntanning
and this is downhill stuff the pop was
gonna run over now the cold-blooded
animals what's that mean
that they either body well their body
will will adjust to the fire here right
yeah everyone yeah so so so so that's
what they do they kind of get their
metabolism going I guess you Sun
themselves out yeah now I'm is great
yeah now I'm as you know I'm as you know
I've owned three four snakes and I'm AM
amateur potala so I'm gonna say the
worst pet in the world now listen very
boring I had a Burmese python named ice
called him ice phantom rats my roommate
in college chadman off would watch me I
would kill the rat by throwing it
against the wall I'm sorry to everybody
I'd hurt this Jeff it's a big I didn't
like doing it all hated it I feed that
fear to my Burmese python I had a ball
python her Burmese python had another
Burmese python now just because you own
them doesn't make you an expert this is
true I used to be I'll tell you them
also you also you also love trouser
snakes love trousers next to now but
let's keep my gayness out of this for a
second okay now we know I'm a little bit
of a line right that's okay but then out
here I'm not lying I used to tell you
the difference between what snakes were
of Isis which means it's something like
that which was some less nice give birth
to live young some snakes give birth
eggs some yeah have eggs some snakes are
have a neurotoxin some new snakes have a
blood toxin some snakes have a gyro and
blood toxin Oh
watch out for those you guys blah blah
blah snout treasure trousers a snake um
I'm gonna go ahead and say I'm gonna go
I was gonna say California king now
here's what I think bring up a towel for
you yesterday use a tint of red okay
yesterday I was a terran tactical our
friend Taran Butler
oh you're shooting I was I was squeezing
off some rounds I was they brought my
game up a little thanks for the invite
well I should have invited you but I
thought you didn't like doing it
what oh dude I loved shooting with him
oh I'm bringing you last year I'm
bringing you back oh my back oh yeah
offered that wasn't the snake he offered
for you and I to go and do it this
Friday we could do the podcast and go
out if we want I don't know I'm thinking
I had a blast I had a blast took my game
to another level um we can watch it on
my I didn't put up man scram hey but
that's definitely like king snake but
the point is connected offense I was
peeing I pulled out my trousers naked
peeing I looked down and right in front
of me is a garter snake just sitting
there harmless and it looked like that
so I'm gonna go ahead all day it's not
nothing
I didn't you might have liked it maybe I
didn't take the freak but I think that's
a garter snake I think it's a great
mistake to yeah and not to became garden
or snake it's a gardeners garter snake
game-2 now so you're becoming a bit of a
herpetologist - well you gotta know the
animals you're gonna run into and you
got to know what your mask on it and I
have mascots around saying hey I wanted
a nice [ __ ] snake I want honey
that's a rattlesnake
I wanna before we go on I want to thank
the fans and the sea of people that have
been begging for me to start the thin
boy biker club now now you'll have a
bike Rob merchant I have to talk Brennan
he had a spark
sure is there money to be made I guess
but the blinding I thank you so much
that ditchin yeah you big two men yeah I
like it yep that's him huh that's a big
snake they get big I guess car it's not
bigger Carter snake now people in the
comments were like dude pick him up grab
him he's harmless
not doing why bother an animal hey I
wasn't like bother dude pros cons pros
it's just for the gram cons that thing
bites my [ __ ] neck well bet on my lip
or bite you and you get an infection or
you know what
snake I don't want to be picked this
popping in the thick boys snake tattoo
on his thigh yes yes let's get it Monday
but I was busy yeah yeah I'm just
begging you again thank you for the huge
interest now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]